we're joined right here on the top of
our third and final hour right here on
nbc sports
uh nbc sn along with siriusxm 211 our
youtube feed
youtube.com richardson show a guy who
i'm thrilled to be calling a good friend
of mine not just mine but my wife's as
well
he's basketball hall of famer one of the
all-time besties charles barkley how are
you
charles i'm doing good brother thanks
for having me on oh thanks for coming on
i really appreciate it i knew uh
you know that last dance last night
would uh center around
you and your uh your basketball cross
section with jordan at some point in
time
what's it like to and we had john elway
on last week and he said he was watching
you know the drive
um he was watching himself as the
quarterback of the drive with all these
flashbacks what's it like for you to
watch yourself play
from back in the day charles
well just bring back well that wasn't a
great memory but it brings back great
memories right
you know i'm almost 60 now so
i mean we're talking really basically
almost 30 years ago so i've been blessed
but
it brings back great memories especially
you know looking at the dream team stuff
that was just so much so awesome uh it
was just so awesome
reliving the dream team stuff losing the
finals still sucks to this day
right but man being being on that dream
team was just so
awesome uh i'll never forget it all
right so let's get into that because i
don't know how much of
what you you uh you gave to uh the last
dance folks
uh made it on the air um when you saw
the recollection of that monte carlo
practice where jordan took things over
what what is what's your memory of that
moment charles
well the damn you know i think there was
obviously an exaggeration i mean because
we had so many great players everybody
had a bunch of great moments
but i was just saying the thing that was
amazing to me that was the most intense
thing that i've ever been through
every day uh obviously michael was the
best player but you know
at that time he had ben karmalong trying
to prove who was the best power forward
and we were trying to kill each other
every day
uh you had david robinson and patrick
ewing who were the two best centers in
the league trying to kill each other
you had michael they spoke about michael
and eli dressler hated each other they
were trying to kill each other
and then if you remember magic had been
shut down by scotty in the finals
so he was trying to go at scotty so it
was a bunch of egos
it was awesome but we were all just
trying to prove we were the best at our
position that's what made it so intense
it wasn't just like one great practice
like it was like that
every single day how did daley uh stir
that up
did he did he stir that up as the coach
no no no i mean i mean
listen i knew carl malone was all a
person on my left as far as the power
forward i mean david and patrick were
the two best sellers and
i said chuckling chuck was awesome
because chuck kind of like hey you guys
do y'all things
he was the per he was the perfect coach
uh you know and every because he had no
ego
i mean he always wanted he was a hell of
a coach he always was going to be the
best dressed coach unless pat ryder
was in the same building with him right
and he was
at peace with himself uh that the one
thing that chuck did that you know
when people have debated for a hundred
years you know we played against those
little college kids the first day
and those kids were 18 years old we were
all around 30
in our early 30s if i remember correctly
and they bought these little high school
teenagers and college freshmen in there
they were playing like it was game seven
we were just screwing around
and before we knew it we were down like
double digits
and then we called the timeout and chuck
says get him
and we started killing him and then he
calls he calls off the practice with
them leading
and then so it said that infamous like
the
college players beat us that one day
they kind of beat us but chuck just
wanted to get get in our head a little
bit
so how did uh how did you all handle
that when you said well after that after
that we just stomped them every day and
we didn't take no more chances after
that first day
we just stomped them every day from that
point forward you know cause
you know i've seen grant hill and c webb
and all those guys talk about
they only talk about the first day when
they technically won
but after that we didn't take any more
chances let them get to get the upper
hand
who else is on that college team do you
remember
you know i can't remember but there's
probably every player probably played in
the nba it was so long ago
i can't remember everybody i think bobby
hurley was there
uh obviously grant hill rodney rogers
i mean it was i think like i said
everybody on that team eventually made
it to the nba right they were all like
high school seniors and college
freshmens at that time
charles barkley here on the rich eisen
show a couple more dream team questions
i guess the whole conversation about why
isaiah wasn't on the team
watching this all back right now is this
is an accurate portrayal
of why he wasn't on the team charles not
at all i'm so glad you asked me that
rich because
like i say i don't have when i was
called for the dream team
uh michael uh isaiah's name never came
up
ever uh and i mean at that time me and
michael are great friends michael never
mentioned
black ball and isaiah uh isaiah thomas
probably should have been on the team
but i can honestly tell you
rich never came up
in conversation with rod thorne
or chuck daly i have no idea why he was
left
off the team uh and let's say michael
never
mentioned to me that he did not want
isaiah on the team
uh and i and i can say i have no honest
answer why isaiah was not on the team
but i can understand the nba i guess the
nba
never ask us anything about any player
number one let alone isaiah thomas like
i didn't know magic and byrd and
stockton and
carl and david they never asked when
they called it
charles would you like to be part of the
dream team and i said it would be an
honor and a privilege to go to the
olympics and represent the united states
they never even mentioned another player
until uh they called me and they called
me that one time they had me magic
and michael and larry go take that photo
shoot but we all were on the cover but
we had no idea who was on the team
until we got to san diego i think for
the first practice
well i mean last night jordan's
recounting of it was
rod thorne calling him up and saying you
want to be on the team and he said well
who else is playing
and then his recollection is thorne said
the guy that you're thinking of is not
coming so clearly
this had to have been thought out by
somebody
about isaiah i'm saying i had nothing
to that was so rod called me i was in i
was playing for the sixers obviously yep
i was pl i was actually on the golf
course
uh and he said hey uh uh that's
what's up he said you want to be on the
dream team i said to be an honor and a
privilege
that was the end of the conversation i'm
just telling you i don't know what him
and michael talked about
but i'm telling you at that time me and
michael were great friends
he never said to me charles if he asked
you about isaiah
that never happened so i i've heard all
the rumors for
30 years now but i i don't know what
rod and michael talked about to be so
that's my honest opinion rich
charles barkley here on the rich eisen
show last night too
um talking about jordan being a nike guy
and how he came to be
and how influen i'll give you the floor
here certainly since if i'm not mistaken
you're a nike guy too
how influential is michael on all of
that charles
well he's the most important sports
figure
uh as far as athletes make not only just
the guys today that are making gazillion
dollars for shoes and things like that
rich you have to go back athletes didn't
even do commercials before michael
jordan
think about that between commercials and
now everybody got their signature shoe
and they're making tens of millions of
dollars that's all because of michael
listen we like we can all talk about how
great and i mean obviously in my opinion
no disrespect to kobe or lebron or
kareem or bruce or wilt he's the
greatest basketball player ever
but what his biggest influence is
is guys was making all this money
away from basketball i mean you think
about it guys did not
do commercials before michael jordan
guys didn't have signature shoes
and sell like that's all because of
michael
that to me is great a basketball player
as he was
his influence away from the game
like you know people give him a hard
time for not being a social activist
which i think is disingenuous because
magic johnson
larry bird uh no no guys were making uh
social statements back in that day
i mean yeah obviously now with twitter
and stuff guys all
can say what they want to now but if you
go back in time
in the 80s nobody was making social
statements
but what he did for the snoop shoe
business
and the apparel business that's probably
his greatest contribution to
sports yeah i mean in terms of the
social activism that was quite a moving
uh portion of the last dance um last
night charles
when uh president obama
was talking about how um i mean he
didn't
he chose his words as as obama obviously
always would
um and so beautifully um that he was
disappointed that michael didn't make
political statements and i'm wondering
how that was probably going to sit with
michael
when he saw that well i think i i think
it's a different time
now riz to be honest with you yeah i
think we all make social statements
now but you have to go back you have to
tell at the time
like i say uh as much as i love magic he
wasn't
making political statements uh karma
long wasn't making political statements
uh i don't know who was the best uh
black quarterback and guys like that
i think that's unfair like now i think
guys because of social media
you can be a little bit more progressive
and say what you want to
but also it's a double-edged sword
people only want you to say political
stuff when they agree with you
can you imagine if some of these guys
came out today
and they start wearing trump hats around
you
people would absolutely lose their mind
so people want you to be socially active
but they only want you to be
active if they agree with your point
and i think that's the double-edged
sword for all jocks today
when they try to get political like uh
you know
remember a few months ago when lebron
tried to say something about china
people went crazy and lebron's one of
the best dudes
you ever gonna meet but when he didn't
go crazy over this channel and stuff
he got loud based it and i thought that
was
unfair uh i thought that was unfair to
him because lebron is one of the best
men you're ever gonna meet
but so it's a double-edged sword
everybody wants you to be political but
they don't want they all want you to be
political when they agree with you
a couple more minutes left with the one
and only charles barkley here on the
rich eisen show and i greatly appreciate
it charles i know you've been talking a
lot uh about this last dance and i
appreciate you taking the time
um have you learned anything from this
like were you sitting there i didn't
know that or
someone uh one of one of your colleagues
from back in the day when your player
you know fellow uh players from back in
the day revealed something
i didn't know that have you had any of
those moments through the first few
hours well
i i i think that i would love for
today's player
going back to episode one where he told
roy williams i'm gonna be the hardest
working player
ever and in episode two when he broke
his foot
and he wanted to just play basketball i
don't care i just want to play
if all these young players today would
realize that you can have all the
twitter followers you want
you can worry about your brand and stuff
like that
the only thing that really matters is
being the best basketball player
all that other stuff will come but i
think that we have too many players
today
who they just worry about their brand
and i'm in a twitter fall and said like
no no i just want to be
that's the thing i got from episode one
and two
but i think the thing is really funny
and it kind of makes me sad to a certain
degree
people are gonna learn all the
dysfunction that goes on
in organizations you know people want
sports to be like this
it's all great everybody gets along
everybody's making a lot of money and
everybody's happy
and if you see with the bulls chris
think about this
those guys won six championships and
they hated each other
and like can you imagine how bad some of
the stuff is on
on these teams that suck in the in
sports like this team
won they've repeated twice
and they all they don't get along the
front office and the owners
they hate each other and they're winning
and i hate that people are gonna see a
lot of stuff that goes on behind the
scenes
because you know you hear players talk
about all the time whatever happens in
the locker room
stay in the locker room and that's the
one thing about this documentary
is like nah it's some really bad stuff
be going on in locker room but you guys
don't really want to know that
y'all want to see us play basketball and
football
y'all don't want to know all the stuff
that goes on behind the scenes
that's probably the one thing that
disappoints me the most about the
documentary
well i mean and and based on the first
couple episodes draymond coming out and
saying kd should have told us from the
very beginning he was leaving
and then bringing up i guess tying it
all together
from one generation to the next d would
you did you agree with that
statement draymond was 100 wrong i mean
think about this
lebron just play man and shut the hell
up because
lebron has actually done that
he didn't tell him what was going on in
cleveland he told him after the season
right
same thing in miami and then again he
did it again in cleveland
so kd didn't owe them anything
uh they just got you know he said that
that was the elephant in the room
they just got beat there was no elephant
in the room they just got beat
uh and they probably got beat because of
injuries and fairness
uh because if if kd is healthy
and clay is helped healthy they probably
win again
but listen guys now they become free
agents and they make their decision
after the season's over
yeah i just this whole this whole
documentary has just been
you know bringing up stuff from current
in the past and all that stuff and the
thing that really hit me before i let
you go last night
that last night was jordan remembering
the the final before he
you know took you guys on the one
against the blazers he's only got one
trophy in the case right he's going for
back to back and he's saying
that he took offense to the comparisons
that
people put drexler on his level that he
called it irritating and i saw that i'm
like wow
like that is just that's not a normal
reaction you would think from people
unless they're at an all-time great
level charles
well obviously michael takes everything
personally
and i that's probably the biggest
understatement in the history of
civilization
that michael takes things personally uh
listen
him and that you know you're asking
about the dream team that was
interesting to watch in practice like i
said i was trying to kill karma long
because i want to be the best power
forward
but him and him and clyde went at it it
was so intense
the games were easy but every single day
at practice
like i said magic said it before i've
never seen basketball played
at that level uh but and i think michael
was a man that cause
clyde wanted two things like listen
clyde was a hell of a player
but he wanted to think he was as good as
michael
and that drove michael crazy uh it
really drove him crazy
well it seems that we really drove him
crazy was all the gambling talk too
charles
right from back in the day well listen
i'm probably not in a place of
i got dirty hands i love to gamble uh
can't wait to get back to the casino
uh michael loved to gamble i thought it
was unfair
to try to act like he listen he likes to
gamble i love to gamble do i have to
think i have a gambling problem
i don't think i do just because i love
to gamble
and like i say michael loves to gamble
uh and
to act like a guy who loves to do
something has a problem
i just don't think that's fair i mean i
always tell people i've never been to a
casino
and it was totally empty there's always
been other
people in there so other people like to
gamble also
i love you charles i really do i don't
care who knows it it's been too long i
always enjoy our chats
truly hey man keep up the great work uh
i hope you get some support on uh me too
i mean this has just been a i feel bad
for everybody out there who's sick and
thank god for the first responders and
nurses and doctors but
i'm hoping you get some sports soon man
me too in the meantime uh good luck
trying to win that emmy with belichick
in your group
for the first time the studio analysts
you got bill now to deal with on that
front
you know i love bill belichick he's
getting greeted trying to come over
crossover and sports taking other
people's trophies now
this is getting out of hand this is
getting out of hand and he got enough
lombardi trophies he wanted to come get
our emmys now
that's a fact by the way you're not
wrong that is an appropriate reaction
thanks for the time charles you take
care of yourselves man thank you for
having me love you
that's charles barkley